[Music]
i was reading that you had someone super
cool at your back early on though and
you know this is from my light wikipedia
reading so you might have to fill in
some holes here but wikipedia says you
were
discovered by kelly bryan and as i was
preparing for this i fell into watching
her
entire ted talk which is absolutely
incredible so
one how did that happen how did she
discover you and also given her
experience in the industry
what kind of invaluable advice was she
able to give you when you were first
starting out in entertainment
do you know i couldn't think of a better
mentor for that age and where i was at
so kelly brian oh i love that i love
that you know kelly's amazing and you
know
such a good friend of mine and um was
just
yeah so so basically i was gosh i was
14.
i was singing at this church
event so i'm a i'm a pastor's kid i'm a
pk
and um and it was just this random event
and my dad was like oh nate can you um
can you just sing something in between i
was like dad i don't have my backing
jack so
my mom had to go home and get my um
backing track for alicia keys if i got
you
with the really bad midi keyboard that
was like
like and um and so i sung
i sang if i got you and kelly was there
because
she was giving some sort of talk about
her life story and
you know faith etc and um
and she heard me singing i don't think
she was in the room she heard me singing
and she
the end of the night she kind of was
like hi and introduced herself and
she said you know i have my own theater
agency and um
you know nae's quite young but i you
know i think that
she actually said i kid you not she went
oh i know you can act
she said don't worry i know you can act
which is just hilarious and
also one of the first things she said to
me was um
so anyway my me and my parents met with
her and
you know i think my parents had a very
good balance in terms of
you know being protective in terms of
okay
we're not well versed in this world you
know we know but we
we know there is you know lots all sorts
of stuff that goes on and especially
from
you know a young um a young person
and um to also being like we know this
is what you want to do we want to
support you and what you want to do
um and and so yeah one of the first
things she said to me was oh disney will
eat you all up
i remember it so so clearly which is
just crazy to me because like that was
not only the first job that i got was
disney channel
but then you know i have a bit of a
history with disney um
so so yeah um
so anyway yeah so she put me on her
books and i remember i
started going to auditions i had a um
did i'm sure there's a dutch insurance
advert somewhere
commercial of me like with a backpack
and there's like i'm i'm on a wii
do you remember ski sports we i
definitely did a couple of those i did
i was yeah oh yeah that was great to
look you know
did that winter sports remember that i
was in that an advert for that i was in
a
coca-cola advert doing something or
other
um yeah and then just yeah and then my
first acting gig was
was life bites which is just mental
crazy um and there i was on the very set
that i remember watching going
i could do that and there i was
you